the famous love thy neighbor now welcome
plugs in 10 hope you're well what an
amazing week it's been and first of all
a big thank you on day 40 of this tough
demanding pressurized lockdown the NHS
workers have done an amazing job and
also you know it's not just during the
day as you know it's a 24-hour system
they have a look at the numbers that are
decreasing and the amount of effort
opening across the country is exemplary
thank you so much it's now Colonel Tom
wall he's 103 days old actually he did
get over 13 million and congratulations
sir
I hope you've got spoiled rotten and
that fly by with those incredible
aircraft was amazing
now we're gonna do a spaghetti carbonara
who will do something fingers crossed
the first time this month forty days
lockdown under 10 minutes have fingers
crossed we have a new director of
photography today you may know how but
let me introduce you to go oh hello dude
he's got his new shoes on finally some
new shoes and Oh somebody's as well oh
oh no what happened you just spin around
it there's a nice cool jeans on Titus
look the skinny skinny man dude you
ready for some carbonara dude you ready
doesn't couple now okay let's go I said
I promise
ten minutes now I know I've been sort of
you know picking up or ask of a week but
it's been a busy is it's gonna be sick
on the day right till you set the clock
here we go
let's go please hustle
it started it's a start they can't
really stop paying attention and go
rather come along until Italy can you
gues wearing it today I do that right
hang on get your water boiling lino
start the clock no no no cuz I don't
know she started cooking it this is the
prep okay season the water get the lid
back on okay get the gas on non-stick
pan okay nothing in there get the gas on
we get that nice and hot
okay now from there pen down up and down
please put down please pan down I know
there's a few big speaking out that we
should be putting garlic mushrooms
inside the carbonara but let me tell you
something really important in Italy they
do it with the quality of the cheek and
there's no cream and there's a touch of
regular garlic but hey this is cool so
give your construction love very cool
oh come on sorry you gave us too you
know to come home so at least we give
you is a mushroom and some jacked-up ice
and peas as well so pan down please
fresh frozen garden peas beautiful bacon
here okay we've got some smoked streaky
bacon normal sweet bacon touch of creme
fraiche egg yolks and beautiful
spaghetti take between seven and nine
minutes al dente come on mushrooms I've
got a little bit of chilli there Grana
Padano for parmesan some garlic and it's
such a chili to give it some heat and
I've never been a big fan of parsley
especially they just dumped on the side
of the play sandwich on that and
finished at the end I think makeup and I
was always done with some amazing
backpacked Matilda
stop right first things first get your
pastor in so i'ma do a double portion so
literally take a little curl like that
in and out okay
hold it nice and firm open up tilt down
keep up in okay let it melt don't break
it
I just twist that around okay twist that
round but don't break it okay one of
those nice long strands okay now from
there
and bring her up the ball now like I
said the classic carbonara is telling
the Niblick one Charlie but we're going
to go a little bit more sort of exciting
and just cut these lines into the night
rawness okay
from there I mix it with a smoked bacon
to give you that nice smoky bacon flavor
okay I'm not being clean in there I'll
change your mind on the milk I'm gonna
put a little bit of creme fraiche in
there now wife streaky bacon you asked
me okay it's not the most amazing flavor
but more portly it's got a lot of fat on
there so you get that nice and crispy
okay smoked bacon cut into large sort of
chunks almost like big lumps and then
just go through them so about two inches
long now wait you see the difference
when you use streaky bacon from that
bacon okay stop which is a touch of
olive oil just a touch okay now that was
born into the lid off and turn them
around again and that stops the
spaghetti from breaking up okay from
that bake it in okay now it starts
looking rather large okay I like a lot
of bases in my carbonara okay nice nice
okay I'm from base you have to rewrite
the crystals these we're here to make
sure on the bacon now black pepper is
okay why I mean I that's what Pete's go
in there from there take your garlic I
like leaving the garlic in slice it nice
and thin me okay would you actually keep
them whole or serve it in silver let's
go under for now please
yeah okay a little bit of sort of color
on there but the mushrooms give a little
bit of fuzzy and more potently sometimes
we just call it a bit of fakeness to
Getty you sort of look for the
ingredients but look in jail stop it
please
now now from there spit that out no no
look at that run down please come down
in there or a lightly solve an hour okay
a touch of black pepper have a touch of
salt in there and this a secret for me
just one beautiful red chilli I know
you're gonna go clapping mad why there's
something about having the most amazing
this incredible color on the bacon and
then after that I was like the color on
the mushrooms okay but look at the city
paper it looks expensive Baker now
because all that fat John and that
flavors in there okay from there
everywhere it's okay oh we're great from
relevant other in size of the eggs now I
said you use a little bit of milk any
milk what happens the actual carbonara
gets sort of very sticky Chloe
heavy and you want a little bit of
texture in there some bread some
parmesan on top of the eggs and then
look a nice spoon of creme fraiche of
course milk is fine but it just stops
the whole mixture going dry really
important
hello my sisters you have five minutes
ten seconds so halfway here we go now
look at that no no no please oh my
goodness okay look so you mix it up the
creme fraiche is really forming put a
little water in there okay the pasta
water in there I don't know what this
portal could be it okay excuse me who's
in charge here hello
now from there look Doris from a liquid
consistency that's really really good
right let's check the class done it's
been five minutes you do is tell no it's
not cooked yet because it's still firm
inside it's not blending properly okay
process down please - how beautiful is
that
that's shitty okay mushrooms garlic
chilli streaky bacon smug quencher guess
what there come on this is England some
fresh peanuts a fresh frozen look at
that also I want a nice full Porto
carbonara
okay again prep the single with a peas
in there lightly toasted
[Music]
[Music]
it's very important water this is start
creating a really nice base to wrap all
that spaghetti around this ingredient
okay did we don't put the water in there
the eggs cook very very quickly and you
have a problem it comes gives your
grainy so this is really important sign
now from there get up get everything
ready chop your parsley raising over
finish at the very end how long left
please um you have three minutes left
two days left
we've been fine we're gonna climb Parsi
gonna make it today
I think we're mates today just chop the
parsley once don't go too crazy right
faster we get the corner already down
gasping go on please again this is about
30 seconds away go against the scene it
oh is it though and if your fingers go
through that gently okay it literally
signifies it's done
okay so look just that it should just
break off yes that sticks on the scene
is done
[Applause]
when given this problem please hand
answers right time to dress the custom
done as you can see it sticking to the
ceiling
one more test I think you need 10 more
seconds hello we gotta figure please
yeah okay okay call is over drain
just a touch
season the pasta again there for watch
this is the most complicated part now
get your spaghetti I just be getting
into the mix cut down cut down please no
mixed up first this is where it gets
tricky eggs in turn the gas down now we
have to cook this out nice yeah okay
nice twist
let's forget it twist it round garnish I
never have time for fresh parmesan hello
hello hello
20 seconds
oh bloody brilliant now let me give this
to the neighbors I said to stay close
love our neighbor how wait to see you
next week
you